Okay, then guys, so we're going to be jumping into 2025 back tested for the int
raday. Same process,
we're going to be tracking everything kind of seeing how things performed. Okay
, we want to
get larger kind of sample size of data so we have some better informed
decisions. So let's go ahead
and start things off, shall we? Also, do note that this is a fresh back testing
account and that
I will be testing using start and capital. Let's sync this everything set up so
we're good to go.
Cool, so a lot of the session is open. Obviously we are very much bearish.
Alright, so by the locks of things, let's go to a lot of the session first.
Okay, so third of half. Cool, thank you. So we are obviously extremely bearish.
Yeah, and essentially, I mean m15 swing highs up here, swing lows down here. We
're bearish
pretty much. So we want to be looking for shorts, but when we look for shorts,
probably from
somewhere in this gap or up in here. Let's see what we get.
Okay, I can already see what's going to happen here. So this is going to be the
M1 structure.
Alright, that is almost definitely the M1 structure. Yes, so technically the M1
swing high is a little
up here. So the M1 swing high is bearish. We are looking for shorts, so we
could look at internal
structure. Let's see about internal structure.
That's our two candles.
And the session is finished anyway. Here's the New York.
Okay, cool. Let's see what New York got in store for us. I didn't even check
news, apologies.
We have ISM, we have inflation rate, which was already passed with ISM attached
. Cool. Could be
an area to look for shorts. Meet the pullback criteria. Let's bring this back
here. Let's see
what we're going to look for an area of interest.
Cool, I would be looking at this here.
That would be my order. Oh wait, now the M1 has shifted bullish.
When it breaks that high and then pullback, continue. Okay, now the M1 is
actually bearish.
That's good. Okay, perfect. So this is actually technically now a land of
everything.
No, not a huge kind of grace set up or there's a lot of liquidity at these lows
.
So we're going to go initial balance for 1% risk and everything. It's going to
make it
easier, I think, with the data. Let's see. So we get tagged in and we get
tagged straight out.
And this is 940. We have news that's about to come out.
And it's on news. Cool.
So, thank you.
a lot.
[silence]
I'm still looking for shorts.
Nope, okay.
Nope.
I have Joel to turn. I'm going to get a trade right now.
[silence]
So, I'm still looking for shorts. 1-5th. We have ISM. Cool.
Not sure if there's a shift in there, but I don't think so.
I don't know.
Nope.
[silence]
We have swing highs here.
It's kind of like the last chance opportunity, I guess.
[silence]
That would be our entry.
So, this is the case of pullback, continuation, pullback shift, pullback shift,
break,
change, shift, shift, 1-2-3.
[silence]
This is the level I would be looking to trade from.
Again, we would definitely want to be looking at taking profits along the way
down here for sure.
[silence]
Straight tag.
That gets us to break even.
[silence]
That's breaking and solid management.
Cool. Sweep at the swing high.
internal has now shifted to bearish, but we're still external to bearish.
[silence]
Cool.
No news today, but we do have enough pizza more.
[silence]
New York, nothing.
So, technically, this would be an internal used because the M1 is bearish.
[silence]
And bearish, how about you go up on the 15-minute timeframe here?
That's five a.m. It is NFP, so I'm obviously not looking to, wait, yeah, it's N
FP. I'm not looking to hold this trade much longer, to be honest with you.
This would be a little bit of a discretionary management for the trade, but we
don't want to be looking to hold on to this position for NFP.
[silence]
Let's see.
What's that from a wrist or wall perspective actually?
[silence]
So, that would be 5R, and honestly, it's a good chance that I will close this
position for a 5R.
Just because we're about to have NFP.
[silence]
That's exactly 5R. Let's say that I would cut, let's say I cut 90% of the
position here, which means a very small amount of this position rolling.
And then what is it now? 7.30.
Move our stop.
[silence]
Again, if you're trading a person with account, not a problem, but if you're
trading...
prop.
[silence]
Yeah, it's kind of unexpected.
NFP never just runs in one direction. Like, no matter what was going to happen,
there was always going to be the shift on side and shift the other.
Did it better to take us out? We'd have to go down the same.
4.7% basically.
Yeah, probably not a good idea to even try and hold any of the position to
without the effort.
I'm going to come back.
99% of you are trading prop.
[silence]
Almost all of you are going to trade prop. And if you're trading prop, and
honestly, even if you're trading personal, just never hold up position for NFP,
because unless you are so far in profit, because NFP is always a case of
markets moving in a certain direction.
And then boom, boom.
It's like 9.5 times. 9.9 out of 10 times.
Okay.
So this is a...
But we already have that for news closed before high impact.
Set ups.
It is in a sweet page, but it is also discretion.
You can see there's a common pattern that occurs when I have to kind of go into
using the internal.
It's a strong point of interest, internally strong.
We're going to have to use the internal.
So we'll see how that does as a principle itself, and then if that's probable
for the data, then that's what we use.
The trend is still in that large area.
To a market, continue trading law, which means pretty much continue looking to
scale into shorts.
It's kind of impossible to understand what happens here.
But if we can close below this law, then if we do get tagged in it, we'll at
least flag it for review.
Under the tenth.
No news.
Tugged at 3.30.
And stopped us.
We're going to have to go back to the next slide.
Set in that same pro section.
How nicely we did now in the nephew.
No news.
So we have a point of interest created from New York law London law sorry.
So we're going to have a point of interest.
No, definitely.
And the internal is already bearish.
I don't really see a way to trade that.
It doesn't tag draw in session anyway.
Tuesday 11th.
Okay, so there we have Powell testimony.
So we have a sweep of Asia.
We're still in this really difficult to trade.
Practically.
Technically.
That's our one structure. So anything traded now is considered as.
And so this law is broken is considered as internal structure and discretion.
But then even internal structure.
So we're going to have a point of interest created from New York law London law
.
We're going to have a point of interest created from New York law London law
London law.
I mean technically again that's the actual target.
I don't think price is going to go there.
This is really ruining our intended average intended.
We're sure what target 310.
And stop plus.
Okay.
Thank you.
We have Powell testimony at the end.
So I don't want to trade before the I'm not going to trade here.
There's no self anyway.
It's still 10 minutes out.
Well, at least we're at that really horrible trading range.
We are still bearish.
I feel like we just entered into another really not nice and one trade range.
Oh, we have inflation rates.
So we'll let that pass.
And now we're technically bullish.
We're going to have PPI.
Lovely sweep of these lows.
Pretty much inverter.
15 pips, like I said, kind of the days of those small pips tops.
That gives a one to three.
Could be cheeking tried to bring my stop up here.
At least take it to one to four and then just stretch it a little bit.
That's still unmetigated.
But honestly, at that point, I was just about to say, honestly, at that point,
I want to move myself to break even like when you're so high up the price like
I no longer expect price to come to that level and just respect it.
But, you know, what can you do?
Does any modification like this help?
Probably couldn't manage that bad, so you could have turned that into a break
even at least.
But, again, quite unfortunate.
National target is here, but it doesn't mean the rest of the world criteria.
But I don't know what this is, 130.
I'm not sure.
We do start having the tariff talks and all that sort of nonsense that do end
up coming up.
Okay, we'll join with that.
Thank you.
About to have retail sales.
Yeah, I'll give that one a mess.
Yeah, everyone to enter trade for retail sales.
I guess that's probably going to be that.
No news.
Thank you.
Another one of those dumb wicks.
It's going to go in the same direction.
Oh, okay.
That was a break even, right?
Good measurement.
Thank you.
We're going to scale it into the setup mode.
Right now, that's not what we're focused on.
Thank you.
Hold on a second.
Again, if you look at the purpose of process.
There was $10,000 risk on comes down to $4,000 and then goes down to $500.
And even now, like, push out mitigation above the high.
I was already having a reaction and then it comes up with one huge candle.
Again, it's the small details.
Thank you.
How does the price play out?
Good management.
Can't complain.
New York session.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm going to try to go with these highs.
Not a huge fan of this sort of stuff, but change your character, technically.
Meaning we're technically bearish, but there's no way for us to show up.
That would be continuation.
That's the same price going higher, but yeah.
Further 21st.
We're just in homes of HCOB and we have the federal election at 7pm for Euro.
HCOB at 3.30, which is already passed.
And then probably don't want to trade New York.
It actually did nothing.
And it's existing themselves.
But even here, like, it's a break, right?
It looks like it.
No.
I'm going to try to do it anyway.
I don't think so.
Maybe we are obviously bullish, which is what we wanted anyway.
Still a little bit kind of left to your own interpretation.
This comes down to how you would obviously first bullish candle, second bullish
candle.
So there's only two.
You could also mark it as first bullish candle.
And then we could trade below it.
And then we have a multitude of some.
Right, this would come down to honestly your personal interpretation.
I'm going to take it and we're going to play down to discussion that problem.
But for me, this is like a good quality serve.
Even just for reactions.
I would take it all day every day.
Also on top of the fact that this is my favorite thing to see.
Is this kind of, you can see you have this expensive move.
Slow down manipulation trade out and then shift this entire kind of.
Model, if you would like is ideal.
In taking this nine out of 10 times the live market, even without the actual
confirmation, regardless of outcome.
And be it winner or loser, I'll put it down in this discussion and also explain
why it's discretion.
But for me, I'll take it.
Not because of the kind of delivery themselves, but because of the context that
we're inside of.
For example, we had the premium leg of the pricing of the structure delivery
below eight, London low, no liquidity.
That's all context.
We don't even tag into the position.
Sure.
We're actually in tag.
That's a tag though.
Time to do like 24.
Again, I will put down the discretion, but I would take that.
You can see the difference between the two.
Sometimes that's just how it goes.
We have no news.
No news the entire day.
Yeah, no chance.
I'm not going to try and solve for a one to three when price will appear just
for using M15.
If we go M5.
We also have the actual manipulation of the lows here.
It's a 10-pip stop.
In 2024 you're looking like four or five pips.
This is 10 pips on an order block.
Maybe even go over using the WIC at the M15.
That's one to six point two two.
That's one to five as well.
I see this is negated.
It would be 0.1%.
You can see the difference between the two.
This is one to six.
This is where things get a little bit also technical.
This is going to have to go test yourself.
Moving it up to here and locking in almost an additional 1% because the reality
is it could
be wrong.
It's a lower probability than the way we manage opposition.
It's more hopeful, to be honest.
I haven't even looked at trading this day.
Have I?
We had news in London, but I still need to trade it so it's fresh production.
We're still bullish.
It's one of those same as last time.
That's definitely a break.
You can see it pull back to Eurasian.
Guaranteed, guaranteed, and any other day of feed, that's a WIC.
That bearish candle, because no bearish candle opens there, obviously.
That's a WIC.
If anything above this high, there's open, it's bearish candle, just no chance.
If it breaks highs, now, that's -- oh, here, really.
That's actually a real break.
Don't like these equal lows, but --
[ Pause ]
This here is this.
You see it because the position's not closed yet.
So there's -- we'll have to come back to that anyway.
[ Pause ]
In apologies, guys.
My audio is messon-apprenticesons.
Yeah, at the moment.
But I've got to do what we've got to do.
[ Pause ]
Again, no moves.
I forgot to close half of this at 5R, but it's 5.3 anyway, so because it's --
no, you do.
And that also means that this one closes.
The rest of its position, which is nice.
[ Pause ]
It's a good job, but didn't move to stops.
I did say something you'd have to test is not as high probability as, for
example, our management system.
This is obvious reason for price to come back into here, for example, versus
management.
[ Pause ]
Okay, where we are.
That's just a liquidation.
So we are technically still bullish, but honestly, I see this entire like beam.
Trade is true.
But we're technically bullish.
[ Pause ]
That's a price trade type.
GDP, terrible goods.
We're not going to trade off the back of that.
Now we are probably bearish, but that flush out probably has some reversal in
the back of it.
Or assume, and then into final day.
[ Pause ]
We have parcel link on PCE, inflation rate for London as well.
It would be very cautious in this price section.
[ Pause ]
No, we're about to get inflation.
Inflation rate for Euro comes out now.
And did I already do anything for you?
We're not going to trade until PCE and stuff is finished.
What else do we have?
That's everything.
At eight-thirty.
So it's technically traded from this.
[ Pause ]
Technically could probably trade this, but...
I'll trade it now, for sure, for sure.
It's technically traded this, but it's a little bit choppy.
[ Pause ]
Could management enough shaving a very small portion of risk off appropriately?
Cool.
That will be the end of February.
Let's take a little quick look.
[ Pause ]
You can see here, our win rate is 33.3%.
However, profit factor is 3.2.
And this is the key here.
Average winter loss.
We took our average loss down from $10,000 to $8.3.
So from $10,000 to $8,300, we have appropriate management.
And then every breakeven, which was only two in this event,
both of those breakevens would have been losses.
So exceptional trade management and trade management, again,
here proven to be one of the biggest factors of profitability.
Again, really is an insufficient amount of data.
You can see London forming better thus far.
It's really an insufficient amount of data.
So much traded is -- well, much traded is discretion.
But New York, sweet London needs the most work.
Again, really too early to -- really too early to begin trying
to send data.
Each trade, each one has had, like, a few different trades.
Let's go ahead and move over to February.
into March.